hey this is presh talwalker when you
invest in the stock market gains and
losses are usually expressed as
percentage gains and percentage losses
but how exactly do all these percentages
work out
let's see how you do on a simple money
test
suppose a stock decreases 10 percent in
year one and increases by 10 percent in
year two
the stock does not pay any dividends is
the Stock's final value more than equal
to or less than its initial value
here value is referring to nominal value
you don't have to worry about inflation
question two this is the same question
except the stock decreases 50 percent in
year one and increases by 50 percent in
year two is the stock spinal value more
than equal to or less than its initial
value
I want you to give both of these
questions a try and when you're ready
I'm going to explain what the correct
answers are and what the common mistake
is most people make
both of these questions appeared in a
study downside Financial Risk is
misunderstood one question appeared at
the beginning of the questionnaire and
the other question appeared at the end
so they were not just side by side as I
presented them
981 adults in the United States
participated in one of the experiments
and here's how they did
50.8 percent did not answer either
question correctly
15.3 percent answered one question
correctly but got the other wrong this
is a little bit weird because they're
both logically equivalent
only 33.9 percent got both of the
questions correct
so looking at the results
66.1 percent missed at least one
question
so what were they doing wrong
here's how many people approach the
problem they thought a 50 loss plus a 50
gain would cancel out to be equal to its
initial value
but the correct answer is you would lose
money
let's work out an example to see why
this is true
let's say you are investing one hundred
dollars a 50 loss will be a loss of
fifty dollars leaving you with fifty
dollars then you gain fifty percent on
that which will be twenty five dollars
so that means 50 plus 25 gives you a
final value of seventy five dollars that
is less than its initial value and
that's the correct answer
now this is an example with fifty
percent but the same will be true if we
work it out with ten percent
your hundred dollars you would lose ten
percent which is ten dollars leaving you
with ninety dollars you gain ten percent
on the ninety dollars which will be nine
dollars and ninety plus nine is equal to
a final value of ninety nine dollars
Which is less than the initial value so
again the correct answer is less than
the initial value
in fact the same logic will hold in
general let's replace ten percent with P
percent and we will represent P percent
as a number that's a decimal between
zero and one if you start out with an
initial value of one then a p percent
loss will be the same as multiplying by
one minus P then if you follow that with
a p percent gain you multiply that by
one plus P to give a final value of one
minus P multiplied by one plus P which
is equal to one minus P Squared and that
is less than one
so you will end up with the less than
the initial value
now here we have a decrease followed by
an increase but we can even switch these
two so we have an increase followed by
decrease and since multiplication is
commutative we still end up that the
final value is less than the initial
value
in general here's a chart that shows the
percentage gain to return to an initial
value
if you have a 50 loss you will need a
100 gain to return to the initial value
so percentage loss as an absolute number
will be much worse for your portfolio
than a percentage gain and that's the
money mistake you don't want to make
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of buying your decisions where
we solve The World's problems one video
at a time
foreign